let's cut straight to the chase RTX 1490
is fast extremely fast to the point
where it's out matching the best CPUs on
the market making an actual balanced
system with this GPU rather difficult
it's best use case scenarios are for 4K
High refresh rate screens or for
extremely testing Ray tracing based
titles that's in the here and now but
just around the corner there's a new
generation of games coming where we're
going to need the kind of horsepower
this product is offering that starts of
course with epic's Unreal Engine 5 where
we've only really had a taste of what
this possible vision for the next
generation is really about the Matrix
awakens is based on a new rendering
Paradigm it relies on Hardware
accelerated raid facing it thrives on
image reconstruction based techniques
this is the engine of choice for
developers working on the games of
Tomorrow it seems once we've pushed past
the current cross-genberlays however in
the recent RTX 4 thousand launch beyond
the pricing debate which is important of
course we also saw a vision for the
future of PC gaming cyberpunk 2077's RT
overdrive upgrade is effectively the
most challenging of high-end AAA
Graphics showcases running effectively
with full path tracing on all lighting
elements old games RTX vmix will bring a
range of older PC titles to The Cutting
Edge via RT so that's the vision right
consoles will always have their place
but PC has the potential to offer a
generational leap beyond the generation
or leap we've yet to see but what we're
going to need to get there are two
things more Innovation via machine
learning and wealth more horsepower a
lot more horsepower in this review we
will talk about that horsepower we'll be
deploying our new test bench with an
emphasis on Modern apis and
forward-looking features and yes we'll
be stacking up the art cx4090 against
3090 TI the most powerful of the last
gen cards and we'll also be including
the RTX 3090 for the genon Gen
comparisons and the Radeon RX 6900 XT
almost the best that team red has to
offer in the here and now there is the
slightly faster 6950 XT which the
company did not widely sample to
journalists we'll be looking at
rasterization performance of course
we'll be rolling out some of the most
punishing raid-facing workloads and
we'll be speaking a little bit about
reconstruction yes dlss3 nvidia's latest
AI upscaling technology a temporal
upscaler if you like well if you've seen
our dlss first look we can now dispense
with the percentage multipliers and talk
about actual frame mates first up let's
focus on the RTX 4090 itself based on
the new Ada Lovelace architecture it's
using a new process node from Chip
manufacturer tsmc has 24 gigs of
gddr6xv van 16
384 Cuda cores a gigabyte per second of
bandwidth over a 384-bit memory bus
stated boost clock of 2.5 gigahertz or
thereabouts so I think 2.7 is more in
line with its usage as I see it and yes
450 Watts total Graphics board power
perhaps not what you want to see as we
are prepared headlong into an energy
crisis but I would venture to suggest
that doubling or even tripling of energy
costs probably won't bother you too much
if you're able to drop sixteen hundred
dollars on a single PC component that
allows to Circa 2 Grand in European
currencies and around 1 650 pounds in
the UK pricing and energy usage will be
more critical on the 4 4080 and lower
end parts but even so despite the high
tgp some quick power consumption stats
versus RTX 3090 offer up some
interesting numbers I compared 3090 to
4090 across three titles using our
Benchmark runs and here are the results
cyberpunk 2077 at 4krt effectively
forces the card into what you would
think would be full power mode but 4090
power consumption averages at 406 Watts
which at 46.82 FPS gives 8.67 joules per
frame RTX 3090 at the same settings
13.84 joules per frame huge difference
sticking with rt I went for Metro Exodus
enhanced Edition next something a bit
more sane but we're still seeing 3.63
joules per frame on 40 90 up against 5.3
on 1390. still though average power
consumption of 436 Watts on the 4090
Forza Horizon 5 is fascinating though
3.74 joules per frame on the 3090 but
only 1.83 on 40 90 and a remarkably low
power consumption of 284 Watts so yes
RTX 4090 is more power hungry than any
Nvidia GPU I've ever seen before any GPU
full stop actually but its efficiency is
significantly better than last gen and
while tgp is indeed 450 Watts it won't
be consuming that flat out all the time
you'll note on the 3090 stats there that
the older card is running much closer to
its 350 watt tgp in all benches okay
with that diversion will be an important
one out of the way back to the card I'm
reviewing the founders Edition which
appears to be one of the more restrained
models compared to some of the gigantic
aib models on Route look similar to the
3090 and 3090 TI not as long perhaps but
it's certainly a fatto card based on the
same design language in v-link allowing
you to connect up a couple of RTX cards
well that's now a thing of the past as
is SLI in general really though some may
say that dlss3 has some similarities
with that old technology the pcie Gen 5
power input that made its debut on RTX
3090 TI is back which looks like a more
discreet way to deliver power to the GPU
but chances are you don't have one of
those new power supplies so the somewhat
ungainly adapter dongle requiring four
yes four eight pin pcie power cables is
included in the Box 3090 TI actually use
three there beyond that aside from the
sheer size of the card there's little
more to say about the form factor ports
layout Remains the Same meaning HDMI 2.1
and 3 display port 1.4 A's no DP 2.0 it
seems which won't affect too many users
but may have implications for future
display Technologies and for high-end VR
headsets let's dive into performance but
just quickly I know it may seem fairly
obvious to point this out but this card
should not be paired with a 1080p screen
unless you're into extreme super
sampling anti-aliasing some weird and
wacky things can happen for example
here's remedies control maxed at 1080p
resolution no RT here the game actually
has a 240 frames per second frame rate
limit which the 1490 hits when no other
card does perhaps that sounds like a
good thing but you can see the effect of
the frame rate cap on frame times there
it presents worse than the other cards
in the lineup in many cases at 1080p
lowest one percent and 0.01 scores will
be lower than less capable gpus when you
hit a CPU stutter the higher your GPU
performance the harder it falls when it
hits that CPU bottleneck you can check
out all of the stats in the review at
Eurogamer which has some nice
interactive bar charts but one thing
that did stick out is that when
extremely CPU limited amd's driver often
seems to be more efficient I guess you
do see some decent scaling with raid
facing at the high end at 1080p
resolution but really I'd be considering
using 4K Reconstruction from 1080p at
that point so yeah basic 1080p full HD
results there I still consider those
largely academic
1440p again the scaling is not good even
with a core I9 12900k paired with
high-end 6000 Mega transfers per second
ddr5 from g-skill your gains from the
4090 over the 3090 TI would not be that
impressive for example take gears 5 here
30 90 to 40 90 at 4K we get a very
reasonable 77.5 percent gen on gen gain
not the best scaling but pretty decent
I'd say however at 1440p that Advantage
drops to a mere 30 percent I've not
bothered to render it here but your gain
at 1080p is a mere 8 ultimately then the
more GPU power you have the higher end
the workload you need to get your
money's worth right this isn't anything
new as such but arguably the performance
differentials at lower resolutions have
never been less impressive what this is
really telling us is that the increase
in graphics performance at the hardware
level simply hasn't been matched by a
similar increase in performance from the
CPU so certainly not in gaming workloads
anyway with that in mind then I don't
consider 40 90 worthwhile for 1080P or
1440p gaming and even at 4K you will
find many titles and workloads where you
do hit CPU limits do maternal for
example in this sequence no Ray tracing
but there's just a 46 Boost from 30 90
TI to 4090 elsewhere in the game I'd
expect it to be much higher so these are
the reasons why the vast majority of our
testing will be at 4K and why we've
beefed up raid facing representation the
toughest workloads are where this card
is going to be truly put through its
paces and let's start with rage racing
then we had to work with Dying Light 2
because it's pushing Ray tracing hard
really hard in the real-time info
sequence here the 4090 is around 74
faster than the 3090 TI 94 faster than
the RTX 3090 it has a 3 0.5 times
performance multiplier over the 6900 XT
interesting game really I have to wonder
whether the RT mode as is on PC would
even exist if the Investments Nvidia
made in raid facing never came to pass
you get RT shadows and ambient occlusion
on consoles likely a better fit for the
PC rdna2 cards but push on to ultra RT
and it's all about RT Reflections and
especially impressive RT Global
illumination on top of that truly
ambitious stuff and even without
reconstruction the 4090 is delivering a
58 frames per second average in this
sequence now let's switch things up by
moving over to 4K performance modes of
the various cards here using
reconstruction dlss on Nvidia fsr2 on
AMD we're internally rendering at 1080p
on all cards then the Reconstruction
algorithms kick in they have their own
performance costs but the increase to
Performance is transformative RTX 4090
increases its average to 115 frames per
second up against 47 FPS on AMD at 70
and 77 FPS respectively 30 90 and 3090
TI are still in the mix
Hitman 3 and other title where RT is
pushed really hard across the bench RTX
4090 is twice as fast as RTX 3090 at 4K
resolution comparing 3090 TI to 1490
it's about 74 percentage points to the
better there's a 3.25 times performance
multiplier comparing 40 90 to 6900 XT
team red had different priorities with
rdna 2 but it's the most punishing RT
titles that emphasize the challenge
facing radio on going forward a golf is
still there if we shift to 4K
performance mode reconstruction dlss
versus fsr2 but the gaps close because I
suspect at 1080p the CPU may have a bit
more of a say in the results still an 83
percentage Point advantage to 1490 over
6900 XT dropping to 19 over the 30 90
and 15 over 30 90 TI there's a strong
argument in many scenarios to actually
move to a higher dlss quality level in
4090 in some titles even at 4K
cyberpunk 2077 doesn't make life any
easier but it's another example of
showing what the RTX 4090 can really do
not use the standard Benchmark here but
rather a high speed run through night
City a developer test tool of sorts
still in the retail code at 4K we're
seeing an 85 percentage Point increase
moving from 3090 TI to 4090 that rises
to a 2.13 times multiplier going from 30
90 to 40 90. the new am video card is
nion three and a half times faster than
amd's 6900 XT 4K May well be
overwhelming but there are still big
differentials as we scale down to lower
resolutions at 1440p the 4090 is still
96 faster than 30 90 84 points to the
better against 30 90 TI and it's three
times faster than 6900 XT
some titles do scale more gracefully to
less capable kit however
f122 with ultra RT across the board here
40 90 is 89 percentage points ahead of
3090 at 4K dropping to 77 at 1440p and
just 40 at 1080p
a 2.94 times performance multiplier
between 40 90 and 6900 XT at 4K drops to
a mere 83 percentage point lead at 1080p
I mean the gap's still wide right but
ultimately 1080p is important for RT as
for many users even on higher end cards
it's the native resolution before
reconstruction kicks in for that 4K
output just a shame this title doesn't
support fsr2
we'll end with a couple of titles that
run fast with rt where AMD users can get
a really good experience and where
either the 4090 will lose ground or
it'll produce some stratospheric results
we begin with Metro Exodus enhanced
Edition the first AAA title built around
an engine that demands gpus with
Hardware accelerated Ray tracing
functionality so console release too so
tailored for good results on rda2 in the
tiger stage here the 4090 is streets
ahead of all competition though the Gap
closes compared to some of our prior
results at 4K here the 4090 commands are
58 percentage point lead over a 3090 TI
rising to 77 over the non-ti 3090 it's a
2.87 times performance boost over RX
6900xt finally Marvel Spider-Man you
think that swinging through Times Square
would be the best Benchmark but weirdly
I've found that a leisurely stroll
through Feast aged you can absolutely
Pummel performance in this one with full
RT enabled at Native 4K there are some
sweet results here 73 lead over 30 90 TI
rising to an even more impressive 88
over 30 90. we're looking at a 2.44
times multiplier over 6900 XT here but I
should stress that you can still get a
great experience from this game on aod
Hardware with rt as you would have seen
from my prior Spider-Man PC performance
video this is another game that supports
fsr2 dlss and indeed xcss and I think
that this is the model that all games
supporting reconstruction should follow
going forwards regardless of whether
they're sponsored by an individual GPU
vendor or not the gaps close up
significantly now 4090s lead over 30 90
TI drops to just 13 at this point the
game is running so fast it's hitting the
CPU limit even in this demanding scene
you're leaving GPU power on the table
here with the 1490 so running at a
higher dlss level or even a native
resolution would be the way forward for
40 90 owners regardless 21 percentage
points ahead of 30 90 and 51 versus 6900
XT at this point I think we're looking
at one of the biggest gen on gen
performance sleeps but there's also the
matter of dlss3 to factor in nvidia's
new frame generation technology that
boosts performance still further
well we should discuss whether
performance is the right word an
interesting point raised in the wake of
our preview video DLS S3 works by
rendering the current frame and the one
ahead using machine learning and a
revised Optical flow analyzer to
interpolate a third frame that sits in
between what this means is that at the
fundamental level it's perfectly
acceptable to say that your system is
not gaining extra performance as such
but with that said gaming performance is
measured by frame rate or frame time and
dlss3 certainly helps there so perhaps
your games are not running faster but
they are presenting more smoothly in a
manner consistent with a performance
boost at the cost of additional latency
where Nvidia attempts to mitigate that
via its reflex technology in the preview
video frame rate numbers weren't shared
but quotes unquote performance
multipliers were now we can show all of
the data these are preview builds though
so do remember though Marvel's
Spider-Man I think that's going to be as
close to final as it's likely to get
still let's dive in since we've just
talked about how Spider-Man is indeed
CPU limited on 40 90. let's look at that
in closer Focus here's the Fisk
construction Mission which takes place
in the open world with full raid facing
enabled everything maxed there and it is
essentially CPU limited across the board
there's barely any gain from dlss2 here
versus native rendering that's how
performant the 4090 is in this title
even at 4K Max
in fact owing to the nature of how
unstable being CPU limited can be
sometimes native versus dlss2 sees
native rendering actually run faster for
a short time simply down to run to Van
variances the new GPU basically takes us
close to the wire until we hit CPU
limits so there's not much more to gain
from using dlss2 DLS S3 essentially
takes us up to a 235 frames per second
average in this sequence to the point
where we actually would need a 4K 240Hz
screen to see all of the temporal
resolution when CPU limited like this
Fame generation can essentially double
performance let's go to a heavier a more
static scene in Times Square here home
of many of the best Spider-Man
benchmarks here we get a 14 to 15 frames
per second bump from dlss2 over native
as this is still relatively demanding
graphically but we're still hitting the
CPU limit there with dlss2 DLS S3 by
interpolating between two frames extra
smoothness is added to the scene and
it's not reliant on the CPU at all for
that game interesting stuff I did say in
the first look video that you still need
a performance CPU though for clean frame
times if dlss3 amplifies poor frame
times you end up with a stuttering mess
and to illustrate here's some web
swinging on the same top end settings
with RTX 4090 but this time with a lowly
ryzen 3 3100 CPU which is simply not
equipped to run this game well at Max
settings
poor frame times without frame
generation turn into a total mess when
frame generation is enabled via dlss3 so
there are ways and means to circumvent
the CPU limit with dlss3 as we saw
earlier but the bottom line is that good
frame health is required on the input to
get good frame Health on the output on
the flip side garbage in garbage out
Spider-Man results throw up another
issue with dlss3 the fact that Nvidia
recommends running with an unlocked
frame rate vsync options are turned off
in game to make that happen which
essentially means that your game is
always running flat out I have a 4K 120
hertz screen I don't need 200 frames per
second frankly and frame rate capping
doesn't work in the traditional sense
here with a g-sync screen nvidia's setup
would see screen tearing kick in above
120 FPS on my screen which is
essentially all the time in this game
again not good and not what g-sync is
all about it's defined by a tear-free
experience now Alex is covering this in
more depth in his video but the bottom
line is that control panel vsync does
work but may have latency implications
on some titles and may present canva
stutter issues on others like flight
simulator for example so this is still
early days here for dlss3 more work
needs to be done moving on though to GPU
limited scenario cyberpunk 2077 the
cherry blossom Market punishing on
console and certainly super demanding on
PC this is where we saw dlss3 beat out
native rendering with a nion four times
frame rate multiplier how that pans out
is fascinating
4K RT rendering is hugely expensive so
the first acceleration step is to use
dlss2 performance mode which increases
performance by 2.6 times an average 34
FPS jumps to Nikon 88. frame generation
adds a further 54 percent of frame rate
here taking you up to a 135 frames per
second average in this sequence
so in this scenario drastically reducing
raid counts via dlss2 does much of the
heavy lifting DLS S3 proving less
additive but certainly very useful we're
talking about psycho RT here running
smoothly on a 4K 120 hertz screen after
all the multipliers work in a similar
manner in the extended driving section
which across its length is less
demanding than the marketplace DLS S3
actually offers a 166 frames per second
average again remarkable stuff but here
DLS S2 again shows how it's still
crucial to the experience offering an
initial 2.4 times performance multiplier
versus native 4K with DLS S3 adding an
extra 44 of frame rate on top of that we
had some RTX 39 TI comparisons too in
the first look video where the AI
element tops out with dlss2 and where
the native resolution rendering results
will obviously be a good chunk lower in
the Cherry Blossom Marketplace and
average 54 FPS on 30 90 TI plays 88 FPS
on 4090 both on dlss2 frame generation
gives 4090 an extra push taking us to
around a 2.5 times frame rate multiplier
I also did the same test in the driving
section where
dlss-23090 TI delivers an average 69 FPS
nice up against an average 111 FPS on 40
90 with frame generation taking you to
166 frames per second as I said in the
first look it's the difference between a
good g-sync experience on a 4K 60hz
screen up against a much smoother one
that looks great on a 4K 120 or even a
4K 144 Hertz display
still though RTX 3090 TI still delivers
good base numbers there I'd say frame
generation is a really impressive bonus
but anything from RTX 3080 upwards still
a really good 4K GPU in my opinion
you may remember from the first look
that we also looked at an early build of
portal RTX which takes the valve classic
and uses RTX remix to deliver a full
path traced experience the preview code
we had did not properly support vsync
off operating in something that looked
like borderless Window mode running
unlocked but only displaying non-torn
frames not good for our capture tools
with DLS S3 this game can actually run
in excess of 120 frames per second but
to get some frame rate metfix I used
this static shot I set up a stress test
area that ensures the game runs under
120 frames per second meaning I can
capture all of the output frames path
tracing at Native 4K is hard right which
is why even the RTX 4090 is running
under 20 frames per second here the load
becomes much lighter using dlss
performance mode which operates
internally at 1080p reconstruct function
here takes you up to high 50s and into
the 60s DLS S3 frame generation does the
rest taking us into the 90s there's a
five times frame rate multiplier then
from native to DLS S3 for the record in
this level at least the native 4K
version runs at around 24 FPS on average
outside of this stress test area and
dlss3 operates usually above 120 FPS
so that's DLS S3 Alex has much more in
His companion video to this one coming
soon if it's not on the channel already
it's another disruptive technology in
the PC graphics space and a first
generation effort much has been said
about so-called fake frames and concerns
about latency I actually think the
bigger issue is the lack of an official
way to cap frame rate when the Nvidia
control panel vsync works well the job
is done and the results are excellent
but it's not always an option that's a
problem for me in the here and now okay
the last round of performance testing
and its standard rasterization 4K is the
focus here but 1440p and even 1080p
numbers are in the accompanying
Eurogamer text review personally
wouldn't be playing control without the
RT features but here we are with the
initial bench run RT off 70 performance
bump versus 3090 and a 52 percentage
Point increase up against 3090 TI this
test run has always been problematic for
AMD and it is again RTX 4090 offers up
literally twice the performance of the
RX 6900 XT
cyberpunk 2077 at Ultra 4K is bizarrely
not that much faster than the RT version
frame rates are very low here and the
situation changes a lot at lower pixel
counts performance uplifts are therefore
disappointing a mere 43 percentage Point
increase over 30 90 TI rising to 59
versus RTX 3090. once again though the
4090 is twice as fast as the 6900 XT
things actually look somewhat more
plausible at 1440p where the light of
the land looks more in line with
expectations 40 90s 60 faster than 3090
TI 77 points up on 30 90 while the
performance lead over 6900 XT is reduced
to just to 80 again similar to control
RT is the way I'd be playing this one
especially on this class of Hardware
f122 sees 6900 XT move Beyond RTX 39t
but just off the pace compared to 3090
TI however 4090 rules the roost as you
would expect 49 faster than 3090 TI a 62
Point bump versus 3090 and a 61 increase
over RX 6900 XT at this point you can
see that even at 4K the overall
increases in performance are lower
compared to rate-based offerings but
with F1 here inconsistent frame times on
40 90 suggest we're just hitting CPU
limitations which will affect overall
performance Forza Horizon 5 at 4K
extreme is another title where AMD Ruled
The Roost until the arrival of 4090
seven points ahead here of the 3090 TI
at 4K and 10 ahead of the standard 3090
what this means is that the 4090 while
comfortably ahead is 55 percentage
points to the better 65 and 70 ahead
versus 3090 TI and 3090 respectively and
based on the power table at the
beginning of this review it's doing so
with a mass reduced powered volt on top
of that again though we seem to be
having inconsistent frame times here on
the 4090s suggesting that we're on the
cusp once again of hitting CPU
limitations this would explain the
reduced power draw and it may well be
the case that if we could ramp settings
up still further perhaps with higher
levels of multi-sampling anti-aliasing
the genome jet increases here could be
even higher
short look at gears 5 here which brings
us into more established territory a 57
percentage point lead over 30 90 TI
rising to 77 over its direct last-gen
predecessor the RTX 1390 6900
XT is falling short again here though
with the 1490 97 ahead there seems to be
quite a wide range in results in
rasterized performance then especially
against 6900 XT so I'm really going to
be interested to see how the rdna3 cards
compare Hitman 3 next again no RT here
these are rasterization tests so not the
way I'd be playing it but still some
strong results here for RTX 4090 80
ahead of 3090 TI 95 ahead of RTX 3090
across the whole bench 6900 XT inches
ahead of the 3090 here meaning that the
1490s lead is in the 87 percentage point
region
a couple more faster results to come in
before we wrap up and that starts with
the Red Dead Redemption 2 uh The
Benchmark one here sees a return to the
less impressive performance
differentials I guess 58 of the better
versus RTX 1390 but only 45 faster than
3090 TI still 6900 XT is off Pace here
so it's a 73 performance Advantage here
for the new RTX 4090 and yes we end with
shadow of the Tomb Raider our ever
present benchmarking friend 67 ahead of
3090 TI across the three segments here
83 ahead of the 1390 with the 6900 XT
falling short again against its
contemporaries meaning a 107 lead for
RTX 4090 so in wrapping everything up
then there were big performance
increases here but it's fair to say that
the tougher the workload the better the
bump but on a more General level my
takeaway here is that for non-rt games
in particular RTX 4090 essentially
solves graphics for the generation of
games that we have every 4K raster test
that we carried out here by the
weirdness of cyberpunk's ultra mode
um it's giving us frame rates in excess
of 100 frames per second many of them
comfortably exceed 144 frames per second
meaning that a 4K 144 Hertz screen will
be well served by the 4090 and that's
even without factoring in dlss with dlss
this essentially makes the toughest of
RT workloads good for a 4K High refresh
rate screen too even games we consider
to be exceptionally challenging like
Dying Light 2's Ultra level RT in my
time with the 4090 plan actual games as
opposed to benchmarking them I think
it's fair to say I don't really worry
about settings anymore I don't need to
think too much about the implications of
weight facing either once dlss is in the
mix and that's not even factoring in
dlss3 all of which takes me back to the
idea of a new generation of games that I
started this review with I think the
horsepower is there I think dlss3 has a
key role to play once it's established
itself across a range of titles I'm
still curious to see how to run in say a
fast-paced FPS title for example but
dss3 is also a first gen effort I do
want to see capped frame rates properly
supported
um but looking over the results here
perhaps the biggest surprise was power
efficiency yes it's notionally a 450
watt graphics card but it often runs
lower than that occasionally a fair bit
lower so I'm very curious to see how
that translates to other less capable
RTX 4000 cards running at lower power
limits ultimately though RTX 4090 is a
super expensive high-end card and it's
not for everyone clearly in fact right
now it's only really with a high refresh
rate 4K screen that you really see the
best of it by extension the Ampere cards
well I'd say RTX 3000 still has a lot of
life in it how the 4080 Stacks up
against the 3080 could well throw up
some interesting results based on what
we've seen today but in the here and now
yes there is a new GPU King and it's
quite the thing so I think that covers
everything I want to say about the RTX
4090 then so yes please do like
subscribe share if you enjoyed the work
and ring the bell for those notionally
instant notifications another shout out
of course for the DF supporter program
lots of Early Access behind the scenes
bonus materials uh a brilliant Discord
community and some amazing retro stuff
it's all happening there all in addition
to high quality video downloads and yes
I'll be adding all of the performance
video data unabridged for supporters to
grab but that's all for me for now
thanks as always for watching and
supporting digital Foundry